bella tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono fa vj e oggi siamo
su 8 ott
super super 8 però non pensavo super hot
bravate c'è una cosa dietro che la tua
fermata grazie
noi siamo io scendevo a cadorna dove
devo entrare nel treno
[Musica]
forse era meglio prenderlo fucile sangue
giorno cambio il corpo salve crociera
l'altro il ft era come faccio reato farò
subito un colpo dentro pam già fatta
forchetta sono caduto dal treno cambio
il corpo imperfetto chi spara in faccia
da schiaffi faceva ancora vivono nostro
perfetto grazie ha messo una vita
se vuoi adesso non riesco a rifarlo ve
lo dico per info morire biglietti prego
biglietti o cazzo scusi ho lasciato il
call nel problema credo che sia un
problema a giudicare da come vista
spasmi faceva
ok ho cambiato il corpo era l'ultimo
rimasto quindi ha preso
morale della favola sono diventato un
bigliettaio guai a voi a moggi non
timbra biglietti sull'autobus che ci
sono io faccio un culo così ripeti con
me il corpo è sacrificabile ripeti come
tua madre a 90 borderline cosa mi sento
osservato poi su cosa fare salve sala 1
questo schivato incredibile si sta
chiudendo tutto lì che faccio salve
arrivederci
mi serve cercherà simile in un tentativo
ragazzi provo un tentativo solo chiamato
difficile che culo no fisico alpi porca
eva beh non so lanciare le cose sono
molto scambio il corpo perfetto via
schiaffi in faccia
grazie michele ho staccato la testa con
un pugno caso sono mike tyson
ma porca l'elevata dove da dove che due
palle impossibili
il cazzo sono entrati salde buongiorno
come sono ma cosa sta succedendo
perfetto che culo o no anzi due scemi
non fate domande
ripeti con me senti mi sono rotto il
cazzo c'è veramente ti prendo a schiaffi
il sistema miren mi renderà mirren vera
libero si scrive tutto tacca ecco
infatti io ho scritto bene tu non sai
scrivere i passati dizionario ignorante
una katana figures ma se ci puoi
lanciarci la spada in bocca potrebbe
essere un'idea potrebbe essere un'idea
quello lì la ma perché devi lanciare la
pistola e mi uccide per forza non ce la
farò mai
è un [ __ ] è un [ __ ] meno male
che è un [ __ ] perfetto
nessuno d'asta porta ok
ecco l'ho detto io e porca eva l'ho
detto prodotto deficiente ho colpito la
casa non era l'ultimo su ok era questo
che culo va bene va bene va bene sono
fatta andiamo avanti cosa devo ripetere
stavolta abbiamo raggiunto il nucleo il
nucleo abbia raggiunto
ok che devo pagare una tassa di quel a
cos'è sta roba
la fibra ottica il che stiamo andando le
centrali fastweb di l'ho subito gaia
fibra zio con me ciò ecco la lunghezza
di questo tunnel è paragonabile al cazzo
che me ne frega più o meno un polo ecco
in fondo ci sono le gioie che non
raggiungeremo mai sopra lunghisti cavi
in fibra e basta è rotto il cazzo
ripeti con me entrano nel nucleo no
entrerò dentro tua madre se continui
così
due palle break dove a siamo arrivato
alla fine il corridoio nei tagliato
tutto quel pezzo di strada
prendi il nucleo ma quella del simbolo
degli illuminati che chi stai dicendo
entra nel nucleo premi e per entrare nel
nucleo della piramide e c'è gente che mi
spara in bocca sai come lascia lista a
capirmi sta sparando in faccia e cosa
vuoi che dica no a dono di prendere a
schiaffi in bocca amico sud e
trasportarono ho capito a posto
accesso negato la verifica in due
passaggi che hanno trascinato fuori
grazie amici siete amicissimi e ti
regalo questo porta posacenere
non ho capito cosa è successo ma va bene
ecco fa salve ti regalo tornano ok a
loro mi stanno trascinando fuori perché
non vogliono che io finisca dai veloce
caricamento di merda 58 perfetto per chi
devo trascinare fuori sia poi vi devo
fare il culo non spiegate e così un
[ __ ] potevi uccidermi
tranquillamente proprio io non sono
anche maneggiare le armi 1 donna quant'è
difficile incentrati sul nucleo se se ce
l'ha fatta
ovvio dimmi che arriva al 92 per cento e
si stacca che ti ammazzo c'è veramente
tra noi e valerci 82
niente e vabbè grazie
uno che stava lancio [ __ ] ok spara
però ok da dove cazzo sei uscito è
volevi vorremo ari brutto astra e niente
raga io non so più cosa faccia veramente
impossibile cieli giuro non ora che ci
sto provando il giurì impossibile se non
so proprio cosa fare e possibile fare in
bocca gli sparo nel rene di sparo dunque
porca eva lercia non c'è verso non c'è
verso niente neanche a metro e butta
niente
non mi ha nostri non ho capito che non
mia non mi ha preso veramente l'ho fatta
non per
[ __ ] racca [ __ ] è caduto pure
microfono ma che palle che palle che
palle che lo sto facendo leva mancato da
un metro
sono anche come
[Musica]
[Applauso]
siamo vengono la madonna di squarto
tutta la famiglia visse quarto
continuerò niente quello che non c'e da
fare dislessico continuerò niente
continuerò nel prossimo episodio se il
video vi è piaciuto mettete come al
solito mi piace sulla pagina di facebook
alla prossima bello a tutti i ragazzi
sei stato bravo